we're in three at the moment right mm
three after looking at units of
measurement and then thinking uh limit
our area and volume now we're thinking
about similarity that was the young that
was in title on this unit if you recall
and similar shapes remember their shapes
that are exactly the same in terms of
their features and proportions what
they're just different size right like
really small things that look the same
as really big things and one of the most
common places where we find similar
things in your life uh scale drawings
like maps and that kind of thing wait
you've got a drawing and you clearly
want to be smaller than the real thing
okay so you can actually have a look at
the map and not have to carry around you
know something the size of Sydney so the
idea of scale drawing simply talks about
this scale factor I like idea something
being compared to something else a big
aside and so you just get a fraction
you're gonna ratio right so for example
if you've got a length limit or you
divide it by how long it actually is in
reality you might find that the drawing
is 1,000 for the size of the actual
thing that's representing right so you
might see that scale written as a
fraction you might see it written as a
ratio occasionally when you actually
have a look at a map sometimes because
it's a little more kind of reward for us
they'll actually tell you the units to
which strictly speaking doesn't
necessarily make a ratio because we know
they don't have units but you will
sometimes see a phrase like this okay so
one centimeter to ten meters if you
recall ten meters is how many
centimeters again each meter is 100
centimeters so therefore ten meters a
thousand so this this is another way of
saying one to a thousand does that make
sense so um the idea of scales really
simple to work with because we've been
doing ratios and rates for so long let's
have a look at a couple of examples
stay with this color if you guys
distance you know it happens to be 1600
meters right and you measure across the
pages like on all of the diagonal and
this is how far it is how do we work out
the scale what come out to this guy
right this is just that simple
definition for how to get the right
ratio I'm gonna write down scale equals
and then I'm going to put down a small
length on the top big lake on the bottom
right a drawing versus reality so here
you can see which is which I'm gonna
have 32 centimeters on the top and 1600
meters on the water
okay now that's the numbers with unit
I'd like to simplify that because just
like alright here's I shouldn't really
actually have units there I've got
centimeters of meters I should change
them both to the same which would you
like me to change them to both to 7
meters I could do either way I could
change this to meters and then they'd be
both meters I can change this Isetta
meters and a great about centimeters if
we change it as you suggested
what do I have to do this to no matter
how would I write it differently what am
I gonna have to multiply by a hundred
right centimeters these are lies zeros
it's okay I mean often having a lot of
zeros come a point because that way you
can have a small map represents a big
thing
I've got centimeters on the top of the
bottom now so I can get rid of those
guys and then I can just crunch this
through the calculator I wonder if we
can do it you know just look at hot
think about it
look 32 and 16 they're really gonna have
common factors right what can I divide
through back I could divide through by 8
that'll give me 4 and 2 but that means I
can go again
actually that's a multiple of 6 Dave
isn't it so if I divide this by 16 I end
up with to find divide this by 16 that's
just that's just 1 okay so this is one
with one two three four zeros after it
one two three four zero so this is two
over 10,000 this four zeros which means
it's one over 5,000 so that's the scale
done and of course your calculator can
confirm that for you so working out of
scale is not too hard sometimes you know
what the scale is in fact on a map like
I mentioned usually right in the bottom
right hand corner
you'll find this here that's provided so
maybe they tell you that you get your
all around maybe you all I don't know
okay I could attract or something like
that you're like how far am I actually
gonna go see your map shows this little
little distance and you want to know
what is it reality so I'm going to start
just the same way I did before with the
scale and these two things here with a
slight difference when I write this
scale equals I have short length on the
top long length on the bottom I know it
goes short like this it's 18 millimeters
but I don't know what to hate the
reality is so thankfully I have a whole
range of magic mathematics devoted to
where that don't know what the number is
it's called algebra so I'm just going to
give it a name I'll just call it L for
length okay now I actually know the
scale as well it's provided in the
question so rather than write it as a
ratio I'll write it as a fraction so
these guys can talk to each other so
that's 1 over 250 and now perhaps you
recognize I've got a fraction on the
left
fraction on the right so I can cross
multiply and get something just for L L
over here to the left I don't know what
18 times 250 is can someone write for me
thank you
okay now in theory I'm kind of finished
I do have a link I am kind of done but
it's like we've said before
oh it's lots of 0 I can probably
simplify this down a little bit what's
the next unit after millimeters
centimeters and there are 10 millimeters
for every centimeter so I could write
this as 450 centimeters I could probably
go one more
the next unit up is meters so that's
we've already said that's a hundred to
one so I could write that like so any of
these would be fine you might find a
question and you'll tell you up here
please provide your odds
meters kilometers whatever it happens to
be okay